you
it's not uncommon for a person to grow
up live and die within 20 miles of their
birthplace as we've seen throughout much
of history on the other hand there have
been intrepid explorers who circled the
globe or studied remote islands far from
home but regardless how far we travel
from our birthplace well over 99% of
humans who have ever lived
never leave the little ball of rock we
call Earth even great explorers like
Magellan the first man to circumnavigate
the earth lived his whole life on an
astronomical scale in the same place in
more recent years humanity has started
to take its first baby steps into space
but just how far has our civilizations
reach extended from Earth how far have
we gone on April 12th 1961 humanity
finally became a spacefaring species
when Soviet cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin
blasted off from a cosmodrome in
southern casick Stan starting his 105
minute journey beyond the reach of Earth
Gagarin is Vostok one spacecraft orbited
the earth once reaching a maximum height
of 327 kilometers that's just over the
distance from Dallas Texas to Shreveport
Louisiana
Yuri Gagarin assured in the space age
with his historic first flight and in
the fifty or so years since we've
continued to push the boundaries of
space travel farther and farther from
home on July 20th 1969 the United States
successfully landed the first two humans
on the moon about 20 minutes after his
famous declaration Neil Armstrong and
pilot Buzz Aldrin spent about two and a
half hours gathering lunar material to
bring back to earth for study this
voyage far exceeded the distance
traveled by kokorin eight years earlier
as the moon sits roughly 384,000
kilometers from Earth to put that in
perspective the circumference of the
earth is roughly 40,000 kilometers so if
you took an enormous ball of twine and
circled the earth nine and a half times
then stretched it out you'd have roughly
the distance the Apollo 11 crew traveled
to reach the moon that's pretty
impressive and far beyond the distance
most people will ever travel in their
lifetime but we've still gone farther
the record for the farthest distance
humans have traveled from Earth has
stood for over 40 years in April of 1970
NASA's Apollo 13 crew swung around the
darks
to the moon at an altitude of 254
kilometers that put them at a total
distance of 400,000 171 kilometers from
the rest of the human race on earth in
the nearly half century since 1970 no
human has ever ventured further into the
cold depths of space than the crew of
the Apollo 13 mission however there has
recently been a lot of planning
regarding sending a manned mission to
Mars sometime around the year 2030 when
we inevitably land the first human on
the Red Planet
it will smash our previous record at its
very nearest Mars sits about 50 4.6
million kilometres away from Earth with
an average distance of around 225
million kilometers on average that's
about 200 times the distance the Apollo
crew traveled to get to the far side of
the Moon a voyage to Mars when it's at
its closest to Earth would be the
equivalent of circling the globe 1,000
365 times and would take somewhere
between 150 and 300 days depending on
the craft cargo and amount of fuel you
are willing to burn 50 4.6 million
kilometers is a massive distance from
our tiny human perspective but what if
we counted unmanned probes in our
thought experiment how far has a
man-made object traveled into the void
on September 5th 1977 the American made
Voyager 1 probe blasted into space from
Cape Canaveral Florida
aboard this intrepid explorer is what's
called the Voyager Golden Record and the
materials needed to play it the record
is a message to possible future
explorers who find the probe somewhere
out in the universe the contents of the
record itself are a fascinating array of
earth sounds images and human greetings
the sounds of waves crashing on the
shore wind Thunder birds whales and
other animals 90 minutes of music from
around the world and spoken greetings
from Earth and 55 languages as of May
10th
2017 Voyager is twenty point six billion
kilometres from Earth which means it has
entered interstellar space the vast
expanse between stars this nearly
40-year old probe has traveled farther
than any human or man-made object in
history and with such a head start it's
unlikely that we will ever launch
anything that will overtake it in the
decades to come perhaps the most amazing
thing about Voyager 1 is that despite
its age and distance from Earth we can
still communicate with it the probe is
equipped with a tool that can measure
the ions surrounding it
and in April of 2013 it detected the
presence of a wave from our Sun and by
measuring the density of the plasma the
team behind Voyager was able to
determine that the craft was indeed in
the space between stars this is the
sound that voyagers instruments recorded
the closest any of us alive today will
ever get to hearing the heartbeat of
interstellar space to extend our thought
experiment even further we can include
space telescopes as part of humanity's
presence among the stars
the famous Hubble telescope has given us
the ability to look out into the
darkness and observe things that humans
won't see in person for a thousand
lifetimes if at all it's given us
stunning images of the cosmos and since
light takes time to travel to earth
Hubble can essentially see back in time
and observe what are often referred to
as adult teenage and child galaxies of
the universe
meaning galaxies that form between the
present and up to ten billion years ago
a vast expanse of space and time to be
sure but beyond that darkness to see
even farther back to the infant galaxies
the so-called first lights of the
universe we're developing the James Webb
Space Telescope scheduled to launch in
October of 2018 Webb's incredibly
advanced sensors combined with its
planned position 1.5 million kilometres
from Earth will allow the massive
telescope to gather information far
beyond Hubble's capabilities Webb will
be able to determine the composition of
atmospheres around distant planets such
as those in the Trappist one system and
determine whether they can support life
and most importantly it will allow us to
see back almost to the very beginning of
the universe just a few hundred million
years after the Big Bang with advanced
telescopes like Webb humanity's reach
will go far beyond what we can ever hope
to accomplish with manned missions
seeing far into the breathtaking depths
of space and while we may not be able to
visit all the hundreds of billions of
galaxies at least we can know our place
among them if you'd like to learn more
about any of the topics covered in this
video check out the links in the
description make sure to subscribe if
you haven't already and leave a comment
down below with what you think of the
future of space exploration you can
watch my other space themed videos by
clicking here or watch all my videos by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video